let's do a little warm-up now before
moving to the central topic of today's
lecture on how to apply these transition
probabilities in order to calculate some
more interesting path behaviors of
Markov chains so suppose that you are
given the following Markov chain and
you're asked to calculate the
probability that starting in state 1 you
go successively in state 2 then state 6
and then 7 so this is really what we are
asked here you start at 1 then you go to
2 6 & 7 so how to calculate such a
probability well we can use a version of
the multiplicative rule that we have
introduced before and so what what is
the specific format of that rule that
I'm gonna use here is you have 3 event
like that B C D they are conditioned on
a and I will say that this is the
priority of B given a time's the poverty
of C given a intersection B times the
probability of D given a intersection B
intersection C so this is a version of
the multiplicative rule right and this
is we are going to use here so let's do
it
this is going to be equal to the
probability that X 1 equals 2 given X 0
equals 1 times the probability that X 2
equals 6 given X 0 equals one and x 1
equals 2 times the whole DT that x 3
equals 7 times X 0 equals 1 x 1 equals 2
and then X 2 equals 6 right so
multiplication rule
now here this is p1 2 and here we are
using the moko property
what it says here is what is the
probability that I will be in state 6
given that I was in 1 and then 2 and we
know that having the entire trajectory
doesn't matter it's just the last step
so it's essentially talams this one is
p2 6 and for the same reason this one is
nothing else than P 6 7 the important
message here is that to find the
probability of a specific trajectory
like this one you just need to multiply
the transition probabilities that you
find along the trajectory right so this
is what we have here now suppose that
you want to find the priority that in 4
time steps you find yourself in a
specific state say 7 given that you
store it in a specific initial state say
- right now this is really what we want
here you're here and then you want up
here after 4 steps so how do you
calculate that well one way is to use
our recurrence formula for R IJ that we
have described before another for small
examples like this one when the number
of time steps in the future is small in
that case for one can perhaps use a
brute force calculation so what is the
brute force calculation well you try to
enumerate all possible trajectories and
then you sum all their probabilities so
in that case I think we have three
trajectories
but I'm not through Schewel so let's try
to enumerate them so one possibility so
you start here and one possibility and
once the transition is to go to 6 right
then from 6 you go to 7 then from 7 you
go back to 6 and then from 6 you again
go to 7 right so that if we look and use
the rule that we have developed before
it would be the priority
of going to six times P six seven times
P seven six and time P six seven so this
is one way of doing it what would be
another path well from two you could
instead of going to six you could go to
one in one transition then you go back
to two then we go to six and then right
up to seven so essentially here what we
have is plus P 2 1 times P 1 2 times P 2
6 times P 6 7 and what is the third way
to do that so there is a third path
you're starting from here yes you go
here in one step here you do a jump out
himself and step and never jump and then
you go to seven so in that case you
would have plus P 2 six times P six six
times P six six times P six seven so
here we have the entire solution right
so this is what is called by brute force
now of course if instead of four here
you had something like 200 write the
number of trajectories would grow
exponentially with this number of steps
and this is not practical anymore
using the recursion formula would have
been a much better approach and in some
sense would have a much better
complexity essentially a linear growth
as a function of time steps in the
future more precisely for a chain with a
state space of M each time steps you
need to update all RI J's so for each
pair of IJ so each updates would take a
bat and square
and so the toll computational complexity
would grow about n times M square as a
function of N